[Music]  that's why we're here on vacation that's  what it's all about it seems like  Kourtney Kardashian's 38th birthday  girl's trip to Mexico is seriously lint  [Music]  court is in Tulum with several of her  gal pals including sister Kim who gave  fans a play-by-play of the wilds  festivities on Twitter Monday night  here's just a few of the highlights  Kim alleges Kourtney threw up in her bed  and did a whole bunch of naked  cartwheels she's like the hottest mom  ever there's also talk of nipple clamps  skinny dipping special brownies and some  twerking not everything in life is so  serious I'm always so uptight the group  seems to be having a total blast  we're not exactly used to seeing this  side of Kim but we 100% like it you just  gotta roll with it  [Music]  you